we're not going to go into more detail
on multinomial regression now what we're
going to do is tell you about a
different classification method which is
called discriminant analysis which is
also very useful and it approaches a
problem from a really quite different
point of view
in discriminate analysis the the idea is
to model the distribution of X in each
of the classes separately
and then use what's known as Bayes
theorem to flip things around to get the
probability of Y given X
in this case for the linear discriminant
analysis we're going to use gaussian
distributions for each class
and that's going to lead to linear or
quadratic discriminant analysis so those
are the two popular forms
but as you'll see this approaches is
quite General and other distributions
can be used as well
but we'll focus on normal distributions
so what is Bayes theorem for
classification so it sounds pretty scary
but not too bad so of course Thomas
Bayes was a famous mathematician
and his name now today represents a
burgeoning subfield of statistical and
and probably ballistic modeling but here
we're going to focus on a very simple
result which is known as Bayes theorem
and it says that the probability of y
equals K given x equals x so you've got
the ideas you've got two two variables
in this case we've got Y and X
and we be looking at aspects of the
joint distribution
so this is what we after the probability
of y equals K given X
and base theorem says you can flip
things around you can write that as the
probability that X is x given y equals k
that's the first piece on the on the top
there
multiplied by the marginal probability
or prior probability that Y is K
and then divided by
the marginal probability that x equals X
so this is just a formula from
probability Theory but it turns it out
it's really useful and is the basis for
discriminant analysis
and so
we write things slightly differently in
the case of discriminant analysis
so this probability y equals k
is written as Pi k
so if there's
if these three classes are going to be
three values for pi just the probability
for each of the classes but here we've
got class little K so that's Pi k
probability that
X is x given y equals K well if x is a
is a quantitative variable
um we re what we write for that is the
density so that's a probability density
function for X in class K
and then the marginal probability of of
X is just this expression over here
so this is summing over all the classes
okay
and and so that's how we use Bayes
theorem to get to the probabilities of
Interest which is y equals K given X
now at this point it's still quite
General we can plug in any probability
densities but now what we're going to do
is go ahead and plug in the gaussian
density
for f sub K of x
um before we do that let me just show
you a little picture to to make things
clear
in the left-hand plot what have we got
here we've got a plot against X single
variable X
and in the vertical axis what we've got
is actually Pi sub k
and multiplied by F sub K of x
for both classes k equals 1 and k equals
2.
now in this case
so remember in the previous Slide the
probability was essentially proportional
to Pi sub K times F sub K of x
and in this case the the pies are the
same for both so it's really to do with
which density is the highest
and you can see that
the decision boundary or the vertical
dashed line is at zero and that's the
point at which the green density is
higher than the purple density
and so anything to the left or zero we
classify as as green
and anything to the right we'd classify
as as purple
okay and it sort of makes sense that
that's what we do there
the right hand plot has has different
priors
so yeah
the probability of 2 is 0.7 and and of
of 1 is 0.3
and now again
we've multiple we we plot in pi sub k
times F sub K of x
against X and that bigger prize has
bumped up the purple and what it's done
is moved the decision boundary slightly
to the left
and that makes sense too again it's
where they intersect
that makes sense as well because we've
got more we've got more purples here
actually I say are they pinks it looks
purple to me
um there's more of them so everything
else being equal we're going to make
less mistakes if we if we classify it to
to purples and to to Greens
okay so that's a row that's how these
these priors and and the densities play
a role in classification
okay so so why does criminant analysis
it seemed like logistic regression was a
pretty good tool well it is but it turns
out there's a room for discriminant
analysis as well
and so I there's three points we make
here when the classes are well separated
it turns out that the parameter
estimates for logistic regression are
surprisingly unstable in fact if you've
got a feature that separates the classes
perfectly the coefficients go off to
Infinity
so it really doesn't do well there
the district regression was developed in
in the largely in the biological and
medical Fields where you never found
such strong predictors
now you can do things to to to make
logistic regression better behave but it
turns out linear discriminant analysis
doesn't suffer from this problem and is
better behaved in those situations
also if any small the sample size is
small and the distribution of the
predictors x is approximately normal in
in each of the classes it turns out the
linear regression discriminant model is
again more stable than logistic
regression
and finally if we got more than two
classes we'll see logistic regression
gives us nice low dimensional views of
the data and the other point remember in
the very first section we showed that
the Bay's rule if you have the right
population model the Bayes rule is the
best you can possibly do right so if our
normal assumption is right here right
then then the this Bayes rule from the
scrim analysis from the Bayes rule is is
the best you can possibly do good point
Rob